state board of trustees taking on some  controversial agenda items this week  they'll be discussing superintendent dr  jesus jarrah's employment and  allegations of a hostile work  environment dr jarrah was fired almost  three weeks ago in a 4-3 vote his last  day set to be december first he's  seeking 2 million dollars in addition to  his contract payout  i guess the first thing that came to my  mind was  when i saw hostile work environment and  harassment first thing that came to my  mind was  the anti-racism policy  the children in our schools our  educators  what they are going through  i don't believe they've asked for two  million dollars  that was board president linda cavazos  trustee irene cepeda who originally  voted to fire jarrah is the one who's  requesting this re-vote so come thursday  trustees will first vote on whether to  bring that agenda item back and then if  that passes they'll be voting on whether  to keep jarrah as superintendent